les enfants et le divorce les députés
ont adopté hier soir un projet de loi
sur l'exercice de l'autorité parentale
pour les enfants du divorce mais
également pour les enfants naturels
parmi les nouveautés ce texte permet aux
enfants de parents divorcés d'être placé
sous l'autorité conjointe du papa et de
la maman
claude crespo elle ne s'appelle pas
caroline mais virginie elle a 4 ans elle
est la fille naturelle de bruno fruit
d'une première expérience de couple
douloureuse et puis un jour elle est
enlevée par l'ex compagne de bruno
toussaint 3 5 mois de cette vie que je
m'occupais 116 mort de ma fille la
brigade des mineurs est venu et puis
elle m'a pris mon enfant
ça aurait pu se passer autrement et
pendant deux mois et demi j'ai perdu ma
gosse en france six cent mille enfants
naturels comme virginie pour eux et
leurs parents
peu de changements avec la nouvelle loi
mais néanmoins simplification des
procédures pour les pères naturel dans
l'exercice de leur autorité parentale
pour les enfants du divorce autorité
parentale conjointe du père et de la
mère lieu de résidence c'est le juge qui
décide droit de visite
pas de changement grandes décisions
participation accrue du conjoint qui n'a
pas la garde et en cas de problème
le juge devra entendre les enfants de
plus de 13 ans cela concerne en france
un million d'enfants de parents séparés
ou divorcés